[Music]
crystal joins us in bakersfield
california crystal welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you i appreciate you guys having
me sure how can we help
so um
it's i'm almost embarrassed to say it
but um
so my husband and i um are
after calculating it today we have
between the both of us we have 13 000
in credit card debt um and a lot of it
was accumulated from his past job where
he got paid way less than he is now um
and so we're just trying to get out of
debt and
shredder credit cards for good and just
never use them again um but and and so
we're just trying to figure out like
what what's the best way to tackle that
um you know getting rid of that debt and
i don't know i guess kind of how to
approach it
sure well crystal number one great job
yeah of just looking at it i think thank
you the unknown
um
is scarier
than once you bring it all out and yes
and even if 13 000 feels overwhelming to
you and you're like oh my gosh i can't
believe that at least it's there and
that takes a level of courage to do that
so so i'm just curious how long do you
feel like you kind of lived in the dark
versus just today calculating everything
how long has this been
um
it's been
i'd say it's been probably
over a year now that we um
i i don't know i just i've kind of been
on board for a bit but my husband wasn't
so much where i was kind of like
he he wants to get out of debt but he
kind of continued to swipe his card
swipe his card and i'm like we can't no
we can't keep doing that and so so
what's changed since then what was that
was there a moment did you guys do
something
yeah so actually um
i watched a lot of y'all's youtube
videos and um i brought one up and
showed it to him and
and i think it was like a huge
eye-opener for him and i both actually
um it just
we realized so much because it's like
now that the job that we're at i i feel
like he's making such great income for
what we used to be and i told him
where's oliver i've been going to and
i'm like wow look at how much credit
card debt we have like we need to be
smarter with our money and we need to
get out of the set you know if we ever
want to make something of ourselves and
have a home and yeah leave something
behind for our kids that's all right so
you all feel like that was an eye opener
yeah kind of an i had it moment like i'm
done
we see there's a different way and we're
ready we're ready to tackle so is there
any other debt crystal besides the 13
000 and credit cards
okay so there it and this one's big and
we we've been talking about just so we
have a truck right now currently
um that was a an idiot but we got a um a
brand new dodge last year
um if the dodge ram and it's it's pricey
and so we looked at selling it and we
would actually if we sell it right now
we would actually make two thousand
dollars off of it for selling so if we
sell it so we kind of
we're at the point that we want to sell
it but we just need to get a vehicle
that's going to work for us because we
do need a
truck to be able to haul our horses
um and so what's the truck yeah
um
the truck is worth i've called different
places if i start to do a dealer which
we don't want to do we want to go the
private way um it looks like it's
about around 62 000 currently
what's your household income yeah so
our household income
uh trying to think so are you asking
yearly or monthly uh yearly
yearly okay um i should have calculated
that that's okay what's this what is it
a monthly okay right now we're making 4
500 a month um before taxes are taken
out okay
that's great yeah
that's about and actually he has done a
stay-at-home mom
myself that's about 54 000 gross
multiplied out
okay
and you guys have a 62 000 truck
yes that's a lot of truck
yes it's a lot of truck absolutely too
much truck for us i agree that thing's
that thing's getting sold today
if i'm you guys and if you're serious
about it
we are completely serious yes
and then chris what you're gonna have to
find is an is a truck an old truck
not a pretty truck
the more flaws the better what they call
a farm truck here in the south
that i want to get rusting off yes that
you can at least hook up the horses too
so you can work because i know that's
part of part of the gig there that of
what you're doing
but but yeah yeah you guys you're gonna
make some radical changes some radical
changes and uh i'm so thankful you both
are
willing to do that
um
because it is going to take a level of
sacrifice but you guys can do this yep
like george sell the truck the thirteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt is
there multiple credit cards or is it
just one
um it's my credit card and his we have
it's two different two okay
so what so what's the what's the two
amounts on each
uh
the two amounts on each so
um i i honestly just calculated it
between the both and it was like 13
grand if i added it up which one it has
oh gotcha uh my husband says okay okay
so we're gonna pay his off we're gonna
tell the truck tomorrow right so the
truck's gonna be gone in our head right
and we're gonna take did you guys have
any other savings
um so we do he just got his christmas
bonus so we have
i think it's around 20 it's almost 2500
not to be exact i need it okay i need to
see that i think it's almost 2500. okay
so i would i would take a thousand out
of that and have for your emergency your
starter emergency fund that'll be baby
step one
and then once the truck is sold and you
have a couple of thousand maybe you save
up a little bit more but again
i'm telling you crystal this is not a
pretty truck you're not going to be just
save until the day is long for this
thing like you're going to get something
quick
something inexpensive that you can pay
for
and then you guys are going to do a
written budget together and you're going
to start squeezing out because you guys
have been
um there's not to shame you but i just i
know it because we get these calls all
the time it's just kind of we're just
living life we're kind of just doing it
the money's going in the money's going
out we don't have any control i mean
you're going to know like the back of
your hand exactly what every bill is
what the utilities are what you're
paying for groceries and food like you
are really really going to tighten this
up and then you're going to look and say
okay man we are we are going out to
dinner here we're taking that money and
throwing it at the credit card what i
would have done shopping or throw it at
the credit card all of his swiping
because he's just kind of going done
with that that's all going to the credit
card i mean you really you guys are
going to buckle down and and you guys
can do this i mean that 13 000 you can
pay this off crystal you guys can do
this this is this is not a hopeless
situation but it's the behavior that i'm
most concerned about with you guys right
the idea that it was kind of we're kind
of in and out we kind of want to kind of
don't but once you got it and if you
guys commit crystal if you guys commit
18 months of your life
18 months of your life your entire
financial
trajectory will change i'm telling you
right now
i'm fired up i might sell this truck for
them if they don't i'm pumped
have you guys been through financial
peace university
i'm so sorry um no uh we have not i
actually just bought the book um through
amazon and it's supposed to be here soon
um it's the
what is it the one where he's trading
the credit card the total money makeover
but
yes there you go three yeah
but no we haven't done this yeah so
haven't been at financial peace
university yet yeah so maybe ramsay plus
were you gonna gift that yeah you know
what on top of the book since you
already got that i want to gift you guys
a year membership to ramsey plus while
you're reading the book watch the videos
in financial peace university and it's
also going to give you access to our
premium every dollar budgeting tool like
rachel talked about you guys got to get
on a written plan you gotta meet weekly
at this point and go where are we
spending money we got to track this
thing we're not going to go above what
we said we're going to go and this debt
is going to get paid off really fast i
mean it's 13 000
making 54. you guys could do this
this is not impossible but it's going to
take some sacrifice thank you guys
thank you i needed to hear that and and
actually he's going to be getting a
raise um come january he'll be making
5200 a month and he's like we need to do
that i think that's even bigger
that's right don't let the lifestyle
creep happen crystal i know it's not
going to for you i hear it in your voice
but man throw all that at the debt and
you guys get out of debt quickly yep
it's awesome hang on jenna's going to
pick up and she'll get you guys hooked
up with a ramsey plus membership call us
back when you're debt free we'd love to
hear it